michael lewis his books Moneyball and
the blindside became Hollywood hits the
best-selling author now turns his
critical eye toward the federal
government his new book the fifth risk
examines the transition from the Obama
administration to the Trump
administration and what he says went
wrong with the handover Louis examines
three cabinet departments Agriculture
Energy and Commerce he says the day
after the election no one from the
incoming administration showed up and
many of the planned briefings never
happened yellow so we reached out to the
White House and those departments for
comment we only heard back from the
National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration which falls under the
Commerce Department in the book Louis
writes at the nominee to lead that
agency wants to privatize weather data
something he says will negatively
negative negatively rather impact
Americans NOAA says it doesn't comment
on appointments Michael Lewis joins us
now to discuss the book I have to tell
you it's a great read Michael Lewis
Bravo to you thank you let's start with
the beginning where you say lost in
transition because the way it starts it
doesn't seem like the Trump
administration even realizes they need
to have a transition plan in place
slightly more complicated than that
hmm Chris Christie had built multi
hundred person team to go in the day
after the election filled with actually
qualified people to do it and Trump
fired the entire team the day after the
election so what you had on the one hand
was the Obama administration had said
really defeated about a thousand people
over the course of a year two big
briefing they created what is amounts to
the best course ever created and they on
how the government works and it's not an
ideological course it's sort of like go
to the Center for Disease Control how
did you handle the Zika outbreak so you
know how to handle it if it happens
again I mean it really is a lot of very
practical stuff and much of it is this
crisis management and these books these
briefings just never happen this is like
passing on best practices you know so
here's the transition we're gonna help
you out happens between a Democrat and
Republican and the Republicans just
didn't show up to meetings at all the
the Trump administration didn't show up
at all so oftentimes I say waiting
Michaels or people were waiting the your
population was waiting there were a
parking spot set aside and little finger
sandwiches that went stale
unbelievably sad the people were they
were kind of wounded about all this so
what I do is go get the briefings so I'm
the first person when I go knock on
people's doors and say I wouldn't know
how the how the Weather Service works
there people will say to me I'm so glad
you called because no one has had I've
not had a chance to give my briefing yet
those houses though Michael you would go
fine people what would you have said to
the Trump administration mr. because it
all left yeah and this matters because
it's not just still finger sandwiches
these are the people who handle the big
stuff that can go wrong that we are not
thinking about but it's too late once we
start to we have a problem in this
country but it is that we have this
daily news thing that happens and in the
background there's this thing called the
government and the government is
actually you know you want to think
about what it is it's a portfolio of
risks that get managed and and
catastrophic risks in many cases and
many of them are things that you would
not even imagine a risks I mean it's
like what well how about the risk that
in income inequality gets so bad that
there's a revolution in the country or
how about the how about the risk that
basic science doesn't get done that
might lead to the cure for cancer which
which is you know there's a process
that's going on there how about the
money supply getting debased the
Department of Energy controlling nuclear
science I mean there's a when Trump this
was in the end this is kind of what
triggers me is when Rick Perry is
nominated to be the Secretary of Energy
he had said he wanted to eliminate the
department as a presidential candidate
they couldn't remember its name now you
make a couple of calls and you realize
this department holds all the nuclear
weapons and those nuclear weapons are
assembled in the panhandle of Texas
where he was governor and he didn't know
they did that I mean I just that was
that ends up being typical little this
the idea that you don't need to know
anything to run this enterprise is at
the bottom of the Trump administration
you talk about the caliber of the people
that were in the White House and then
you talk about the people that were
brought in to replace them can you talk
about the contrast not just the White
House the federal government right so so
I mean in a couple what little example
yeah you know inside of the Department
of Agriculture which is this vast
complicated enterprise that if we didn't
have it it would be catastrophic there
is a three billion dollar a year program
to invest in basic science and the
science is preparing us for essentially
preparing
us to have a food supply after climate
change I mean it enables to adapt the
food supply to climate change and the
person running that was a woman named
Cathy woteki and she was an exquisitely
trained scientist who had been in the
job for a couple of deck you know jobs
like that for a couple of decades she'd
done original research that was
breathtakingly interesting she's
replaced by a right-wing talk-show radio
host from Iowa who has no science
background at all
and he's supposed to administer this
three billion dollar budget and decide
who's gonna get the money to do what
research I mean this sort of stuff
happened oh you talk about a truck
driver a clerk from AT&T a country club
attendant or now have government
positions yes that they are not all the
the only requirement for the people who
were thrown into these jobs were they
exhibited loyalty to Donald Trump and he
cared about nothing else all right
Michael does we're gonna have to leave
it there thanks again thanks for having
me thank you